DENIED THAT POSITIVE EXPERIENCE.
>> Shannon: THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> IN TONIGHT'S WHATEVER
HAPPENED TO SEGMENT.
THE REMAINS OF AMERICAN WAR
HEROES RETURNED FROM NORTH
KOREA.
IT LOOKED LIKE THERE WAS A
SIGNIFICANT BREAK THROUGH BUT
THE OUTLOOK HAS CHANGED.
>> ♪ ♪
>> IT'S BEEN MORE THAN 6 MONTHS
SINCE NORTH KOREA TURNED OVER 55
BOXES CONTAINING THE REMAINS OF
SOME OF AMERICA'S HEROES FROM
THE KOREAN WAR.
>> OUR BOYS ARE COMING HOME.
THEY ARE NOT KNOWN BUT SOON WE
WILL KNOW THEIR NAMES.
>> NORTH KOREA HAS NOT TURNED
ANY MORE.
7500 MISSING AMERICANS, MORE
THAN TWO-THIRDS REMAIN IN NORTH
KOREA WITH THE OTHERS FURTHER
SOUTH.
>> WE WOULD BE DELIGHTED IF WE
COULD GET MORE RETAINS TURNED
OVER TO US.
THERE HAS BEEN NO DISCUSSION IN
THE LAST -- SINCE WE RECEIVED
THE 55 BOXES.
>> IN HIS FIRST SUMMIT WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP NORTH KOREA
LEADER KIM JONG-UN COMMITTED TO
RECOVERING FOR REMAINS.
THE SUBJECT NEVER CAME UP IN
PUBLIC MEETINGS BETWEEN
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND CHAIRMAN KIM
IN VIETNAM.
ONLY 3 AMERICANS HAVE BEEN
IDENTIFIED FROM THE BOXES SO
FAR.
DR. BIRD SAID MORE AMERICANS
WILL BE IDENTIFIED IN THE DAYS
AHEAD.
>> WE ARE IN THE FINAL STAGES OF
MAKING SEVERAL MORE
IDENTIFICATIONS.
WE ARE LOOKING AT 4.
>> HE SAID BASED ON DNA RESULTS,
UP TO 80% OF THE REMAINS TURNED
OVER ARE AMERICANS.
ULTIMATELY DOZENS MORE ARE
EXPECTED TO BE IDENTIFIED.
HE DESCRIBED PAIN STAKING
METHODS.
>> AMERICAN SOLDIERS IN THE
KOREAN WAR WOULD HAVE A VERY
DIFFERENT DIET.
WHEN WE LOOK BACK AT THE BONES,
WE CAN RECOGNIZE AMERICAN
REMAINS FROM THE SIGNATURES IN
THE BONES.